it's been a long road but History
Channel's hit medieval action-thriller
Vikings is at last preparing to enter
its final phase after the devastating
cliffhanger of the show's latest
mid-season finale however there are a
few questions that still need answering
at the climax of the best-laid plans
which serves as the show's penultimate
finale the long building conflict
between the ruse and the Scandinavians
boiled over into a catastrophic battle
one that's all brooding anti-villain
Ivar the boneless pushes sword through
his half-brother and series mainstay
Bjorn lothbrok
although the wounds certainly looked
fatal however the camera didn't linger
quite long enough to confirm Bjorn's
death of course this is the biggest and
most pressing issue that the back half
of season 6 will have to address the
fate of Bjorn in the world of television
it's always best to maintain a healthy
skepticism regarding character deaths
and Vikings has always been a
particularly blatant offender when it
comes to death fake outz
one theory deriving largely from the
episodes title argues that the big
battle between Norway and the Roose
might have taken place entirely in
Beorn's head that seems like an awful
lot of budget to spend on a daydream
however although it certainly
underscores the skepticism some fans
maintain about the finality of this
characters so-called death the most
recent episodes of Vikings may have
dealt with the war between the Vikings
and the Roose but there's one major
conflict that still needs wrapping up
back on season 1 of Vikings Ragnar's
journey across the sea culminated in the
brutal sack of Lindisfarne a historical
event that marked the beginning of the
Viking Age in England in the wake of
Ragnar's death at the hand of
Northumbria is king ila his sons led a
massive scale invasion of England known
in the anglo-saxon Chronicle as the
great even invasion by and large these
events were dramatized on Vikings season
for Vikings also went to great pains to
introduce Alfred the grandson of King
experts and the only English monarch in
history to earn the nickname the great
Alfred's great accomplishments in his
life was the preservation of England in
the face of a rampaging Scandinavian
horde and which of Ragnar's to
historical sons figured the most
predominantly and struggle against
Alfred's Wessex fubá and I've are played
on Vikings by Jordan Patrick Smith and
Alex who Anderson respectively
whether or not bjorn survives to appear
in the second half of viking season 6
the war between the quatre guts and the
ruse is clearly poised to reach a quick
conclusion the real question remaining
is whether Ubben
Aybar will set their entities aside to
take the war back to Alfred in the
shores of England
aside from Bjorn one other death may
have occurred during the mid-season
finale that of King Harald fine hair in
this episode king harald sustained grave
injuries amid the chaos of the battle
for best bowl with the Roose invading
from the beach in the river and
ultimately overwhelming the Viking army
king harald put up a valiant fight but
was badly wounded
erik attempted to rescue king harald as
their forces retreated but the king told
Eric to save himself
sorry I'll go girl or find yourself
another home for something to know so
here's the question did King Harald
really die will Eric who historically
wasn't ever a Norse king try his hand at
claiming the throne in the wake of
Harold's death or will something else
happen entirely Vikings showrunner
Michael Hurst hasn't confirmed or denied
whether King Harald or Bjorn had
actually died during the mid-season
finale but he did tell TV Guide that
fans will learn the truth soon enough
Hurst said we've seen the power of the
Roose a lot of Vikings are killed and
Harald and Bjorn are certainly extremely
seriously seriously wounded and likely
to die but what happens after that is
saved for episode 11 Vikings is
scheduled to return for its final ten
episodes sometime later in 2020 check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]